ich bin peter und ich vertrete heute
nochmal den christoph da im moment ganz
schnelles internet halte ich soll auch
das 1 1 1 team einen schönen gruß senden
und auch danke für den support
auch wenn es heute nicht mehr geklappt
hat ein dank auch an euch für euer
feedback zu mir ich werde mich bemühen
und dann kommen wir auch schon zum
heutigen thema verblödet die menschheit
oder werden wir vielleicht sogar jedes
sehr intelligenter eine neue übersicht
studie der universität wien hat
sämtliche bisher veröffentlichte studien
zum thema intelligenz der menschen unter
die lupe genommen und haben daraus ein
resümee über die entwicklung der
menschlichen intelligenz gezogen wie
dieses ausgefallen ist jetzt bei klick
zum science und fiction
das thema intelligenz ist ein sehr
wichtiges nahezu alle fortschritte in
der menschlichen geschichte hängen davon
ab
psychologen der universität in wien
haben 219 studien welche mit rund vier
millionen probanden durchgeführt wurden
aus 31 ländern verglichen analysiert und
letztendlich ausgewertet sämtliche
studien befassten sich mit der
intelligenz der menschheit also mehrere
millionen intelligenztest sozusagen
gegenüber dem fachmagazin perspektiv
psychological science sprachen die
psychologen von einem drei punkte
anstieg pro jahrzehnt und das weltweit
in den usa beispielsweise stieg der iq
der bevölkerung innerhalb von 104 jahren
um 30 punkte
man hat ja auch davon dass wir menschen
verblöden würden welcher fluss fließt
durch basel jede frage wird erst mal
gegoogelt
man muss sich ja nichts mehr merken es
gibt ja erinnerung sap und von a nach b
kommen brauchen wir gar nicht erst reden
wir werden ja quasi von den
navigationssystemen vor die haustüre
getragen
im gegensatz zu noch vor 50 jahren hat
sich aber eben auch tatsächlich etwas in
unserem alltag in unserem leben getan
wer kann denn heute noch beispielsweise
seine hosen mailen früher musste man so
viele dinge im haushalt selbst erledigen
da gab es kein fachpersonal dafür jetzt
wird sobald etwas nicht stimmt der
handwerker der experte gerufen doch wie
erklärt man sich denn dann den anstieg
wenn wir so wenig noch selbst machen
müssen
dafür muss man wissen in welchen
bereichen der die kuh werte angestiegen
sind im sogenannten logik und
abstraktionsvermögen man nennt das auch
fluide intelligenz in einem test darüber
werden so fragen gestellt wie sie
vielleicht viele von euch kennen 2 24 19
31 26 wie geht es weiter mit solchen
werden wir in der digitalen welt ständig
konfrontiert mit solchen abstrakten
prozessen der login button führt uns
auch direkt zu einem solchen abstrakten
prozess benutzerkennung passwörter etc
und wer von euch lieb sie nicht
mindestens einmal am tag einloggen
der anstieg also ist eigentlich keine
große überraschung da 1910 keiner sich
mal eben schnell auf youtube facebook
oder twitter angemeldet hat von online
diensten oder den aufgaben eines
netzwerkadministrator hat da noch nicht
mal einer gehört der abstrakte bereich
hat aber erstmal nichts mit dem welcher
fluss fließt nach basel wissen zu tun
um die frage besser beantworten zu
können müssten wir menschen in der
kristallinen intelligenz besser bestückt
sein
klar definiertes wissen also und genau
das nimmt sogar ab ist ja auch irgendwie
klar fachpersonal und fragen werden erst
mal gegoogelt früher musste man noch
wissen wie man von a nach b kommt man
musste sich die straßen noch merken
heute begleitet uns eine freundliche
künstliche intelligenz im auto die uns
dann auch noch zum ziel navigiert in den
letzten 20 jahren ist die kristalline
intelligenz der menschen stark gesunken
von 2010 bis 2013 stieg der wert nur um
20 punkte an
die auswertung der studie konnte auch
zeigen welche faktoren den iq wert
beeinflussen
und dass unsere intelligenz nicht gerade
viel mit unserem erbgut zu tun hat wenn
der papa arzt ist und ein gutes studium
abgelegt hat ist der sohn die tochter
auch zu solchen leistungen imstande das
ist aber nicht zwingend so auch die
fortschrittlichkeit der kontinente der
länder spielt es überhaupt keine rolle
die intelligenz der menschen in den
weniger entwickelten ländern stieg
jährlich stellenweise sogar um 1 8
punkte
doch was hat dann eine bedeutung für den
in kuwait
eine ganz wichtige rolle spielt wer
hätte es gedacht die bildung aber auch
die ernährung und die gesundheit
beeinflussen die intelligenz um das zu
verdeutlichen zogen die forscher
vergleiche zum zweiten weltkrieg
es gab kaum etwas zu essen der
schulbetrieb die vier stocken bis gar
nicht und von der gesundheitlichen
situation müssen wir wohl gar nicht erst
reden folge vor dem krieg stieg der iq
wert pro jahr um 0,6 während des krieges
um 02 pro jahr und nach dem krieg stiegl
wieder schnell an was uns menschen heute
zum problem werden kann bei der
entwicklung unserer intelligenz
beschreibt der forscher pecnik
irgendwann bringt uns mehr nahrung
nichts mehr dann werden die leute nur
noch dicker er spielt darauf an dass es
den menschen auf großen teilen der erde
immer besser und besser geht somit wird
der faktor ernährung gesundheit und
bildung wahrscheinlich immer mehr
abgeschwächt definitiv nicht
abgeschwächt wird aber die weitere
entwicklung unserer alltäglichen
situationen wie in zukunft unsere
bildungseinrichtungen unsere schulen
aussehen könnten
erfahrt ihr im video hier oben wenn man
das gesehen hat kann man kaum glauben
dass der einfluss der bildung auf den iq
wert abnehmen soll
zur app und zum block kommt die hier
unten und wieweit lasst ihr euch denn
von technischen geräten unterstützen
und was macht ihr denn noch alles so
selbst schreibt es doch mal die
kommentare und damit die frage geklärt
ist durch basel fließt der rhein und
damit bis dann